queen swap off the queens yeah
yeah there's just simply not enough
compensation for the piece right now
black has only one pawn for it
and the white knight now getting active
springing forward
there's some huge threats in the
position knight takes porn is in the air
we also have the added problem that
there could be some trades and the
queens will come off and it's just
hopeless and uh you can see the shake
of uh artemia's head he knows it's over
he normally never gives away never
portrays any emotion but this time
he knows that it's just been a bit of a
disastrous game actually the opening the
clock handling
the tactics the tricks everything's gone
wrong everything's gone in wesley so's
favor
he worked so hard to tell me after his
win in the last game in that end game
but
wow nice finesse there from wesley so
and antamyev
he just resigns wow it's over a uh
comeback in the second match by wesley
so losing game one
but uh what a performance in the second
one winning
the second game